acho que esse é o mais próximo que eu
tive com esse microfone que diz seu
texto bíblico sair foi uma referência é
depois de escutar todas essas histórias
de de como que pesquisadores são pessoas
sérias ou de como a gente sofre quando a
gente está decidindo a nossa carreira
eu só consigo pensar em uma coisa eu
sempre fui uma criança feliz para o lado
errado
sim eu era uma criança feliz
eu não tinha nenhuma preocupação eu não
precisava decidir que começou a fazer é
eu não tinha que trabalhar porque eu
tinha dinheiro da apae da minha mãe
a gente não tinha mas eles falaram que
tinha é eu já tinha meu próprio carro
eu não precisava me preocupar com
locomoção entre a sala eo quarto até
porque a sala eo quarto no mesmo lugar
foi até precisava dessa preocupação e à
minha mãe na época já respirava pra mim
uma carreira como médico veterinário
para os animais de volta e se não der
certo a carreira de médico veterinário
eu poderia ser modelo de roupa de cama
ou de fralda que é inventado muitos anos
depois
aliás mentira as provas foram inventadas
na década de 50 já na segunda
e toda essa felicidade que eu tinha
quando era criança essa falta de
preocupação
ela caiu ela terminou um pouco e ela
terminou quando eu descobri o amor a
estiver apaixonado exatamente quem me
apaixonei
eu tinha mais ou menos 16 anos e foi
amor à primeira vista é eu não sei se
vocês sabem como o cérebro funciona mas
o nosso cérebro
ele tem certas divisões ele funciona
como uma repartição pública
ele tem várias divisões e cada divisão
cada repartição toma conta de um de uma
função diferente então você tem uma
repartição que toma conta desse barulho
aqui que eu tô fazendo a minha boca tem
uma outra repartição que toma conta dos
barulhentos que vocês vão fazer com a
boca de vocês é em uma repartição que
toma conta de ser aquela repartição mais
séria ela toma conta das nossas tomadas
de decisão
quando a gente está apaixonado chega o
diretor dessa reflexão para a galera
velhas não precisa ficar aqui mais a
nossa tomada de decisão fica péssimo a
gente não consegue fazer nada quando a
gente está apaixonado e foi amor à
primeira vista eu tinha entre 16 e 17
anos
ela é muito linda maravilhosa super
influente é super conhecidas
internacionalmente e eu pensei não vou
ter chance nenhuma 16 anos e até porque
tinham rumores na época de que ela só
olhava pra vocês se você tivesse 18 anos
ou mais e eu sempre fui uma pessoa muito
persistente e eu pensei eu quero ela não
quer outra pessoa e me preparei
esperei completar 18 anos para me
declarar e se tiver que se declarar para
alguém
é difícil você treina no espelho você
fala assim é oi meu nome é andré
eu não estava olhando de longe e queria
conversar se treina e fica super bacana
na hora que chega perto das pessoas para
assim é mais um que não consegue falar
nada mas me preparei fiz 18 anos fui lá
super nervoso ansioso nós o ano e com
medo da rejeição
eu fiquei sabendo antes que ela gostava
de escutar as coisas que ela gostava de
fazer e me preparei para isso cheguei lá
me declarei aceitou
e falou assim vamos casar eu fosse
bacana vamos casar eu estava apaixonado
era tudo que eu queria era me aceitou
eu casei e foi assim que começou a minha
relação de amor e paixão pela ciência
eu com 16 anos ela dependendo de
referência milhões e e essa paixão ela
nunca acaba mas é como um casamento
a gente tem que pensar que a nossa
relação com a ciência e na relação do
pesquisador consciência como se fosse um
casamento de casa a gente cria certas
expectativas a gente muda para uma casa
bonita
a casa que a mulher muito bonita chamada
ufmg e ea partir daí todo mundo que é
casado ou pelo método que já se
apaixonou sabe que a partir daí começam
os problemas
você liga para ela assim é que se vai
chegar aqui horas não sei um pouco de
incerteza seria para ele e falei que é
eu tava querendo ir a um barzinho com
você no final de semana você pode não
sei se eu posso mas a roma aí uma roupa
e quem sabe eu vou tá mas eu preciso
saber pelo menos que tipo de barcos e
vai porque né eu quero saber se eu vejo
uma roupa mais social uma roupa mas é
descolada o autor faz o seguinte se
veste uma roupa que pode ser os dois
eu não sei mais ou menos claro que vou
chegar nem sei se eu vou mas sem fazer
isso e me espera lá aí começa aquela
incerteza e esta certeza gera ansiedade
gera tristeza que ele sorriso que vocês
viram lá quando eu era criança não tinha
mais ea gente começa a não procurar
outras casas para morar mas de novo o
casamento consciência ele não acaba
a paixão dele ainda só que é uma casa
diferente porque você começa a procurar
casas diferentes vamos começar a pensar
na relação que a gente tem com a
universidade com o meio acadêmico quando
a gente vê o pesquisador
a gente tem uma idéia a idéia bacana
aquilo que foi falado na primeira fala a
gente tem uma pergunta a gente tem
empolgado para saber a resposta àquela
pergunta a gente estuda como responder
àquela pergunta é você faz uma proposta
de pesquisa
só que tem que ter dinheiro fazer aquilo
porque é uma coisa que a gente acha
quando a gente casa a gente acha que as
pessoas vão fazer os nossos estudos
porque elas a consciência
eu tentei fazer isso no meu primeiro
estudo e depois de seis meses eu tinha
nove participantes
a gente tem que pagar para fazer a
ciência
então você tem idéia se inscreve na
proposta
aí começa a pedir dinheiro é a gente tem
um nome legal para isso que é a gente
escreve uma proposta de pesquisa e pede
financiamento que na verdade a gente
perde dinheiro e depois que a gente pede
o dinheiro que a gente consegue o
dinheiro a gente faz a pesquisa coleta
os dados faz a análise que a parte mais
legal ea gente tem que divulgar isso a
gente escreve um paper e geralmente como
funciona na ciência seguinte tem um
periódico de semana o sp
outras pessoas que são da área vão ler
não vão gostar do seu trabalho
só que eles demoram um tempo para falar
isso geralmente nos oito meses quando
eles retornam quando ele te dá um
trabalho de volta ele falou assim ah
olha gente não gostou muito não porque
não muda isso porque se falou assim ah
sim porque não fala de outra forma
a gente tem que lembrar o que tinha
falado é corrigir da forma como eles
querem entrega de novo fala aí ficou bom
mas demora mais ou menos quatro meses de
novo para voltar porque agora ficou bom
a gente pode publicar agente público
artigo lembra até hoje um dos artigos
que publiquei publiquei um artigo numa
revista muito renomada sobre cognição
que chama cobija
e eu lembro que a co autora com quem
escrever
ela me ligou falou assim não foi aceito
a equipe que já não lembrava mais
aí ela falou não me olha que legal aí
depois a gente foi bem aqui um total de
sete pessoas leram paper e hoje a gente
já nem já nem lembra mais respeito e o
impacto que esse papers especificamente
teve na sociedade foi assim 0
eu comecei a ficar infeliz nessa casa
porque eu vejo ciência ou pelo menos o
meu papel da ciência como eu quero
contribuir com o conhecimento que eu
tenho pra ajudar com problemas muito
práticos
eu não quero fazer um estudo que fala
sobre a relação da oração subordinada
substantivo objetivo direto reduzido
definitivo com a sua tomada de decisão
mas eu quero fazer um tipo de pesquisa
que ajude aquela mãe que tem uma criança
autista
ela não sabe que o que ela faz quando a
criança estava se debatendo e chorando e
ela não sabe o que fazer eu quero ajudar
essa pessoa então foi quando eu comecei
a pensar em sair dessa casa de novo eu
não me divorciei da ciência que a
ciência esse casamento é para sempre
eu resolvi sair dessa casa resolvi sair
dessa casa para tentar fazer pesquisas
um pouco mais práticas ou que pelo menos
tivesse um impacto direto na vida das
pessoas ea casa que eu resolvi morar em
uma casa maior e mais moderna
você pode falar oque gol tudo acende uma
casa rica
eu não preciso pedir dinheiro e as
pesquisas que a gente faz dentro da
indústria ou pelo menos as pesquisas que
a gente faz dentro dessa casa
são pesquisas mais práticas e pesquisas
que tentam resolver problemas bem reais
que as pessoas vivem no dia a dia porque
a gente precisa fazer isso é porque a
gente precisa resolver problemas das
pessoas no dia a dia vamos pensar um
usuário de qualquer coisa a gente cria
um mar de fato vamos pensar no artefato
simples um boné a gente cria um boné e o
usuário usa o boné
agora porque que o usuário usa o boné
dessa forma porque é o tempo inteiro que
a gente está desenvolvendo coisas para
as pessoas usarem a gente tem que ter
uma coisa em mente a pessoa que vai usar
aquilo tem um cérebro esse cérebro
funciona de uma certa forma e às vezes o
nosso cérebro faz coisas que nem a gente
tem controle
eu quero dar um exemplo sobre isso
queria que todo mundo fantasma em pé
agora a gente precisa não queria que
pegasse a sua mão direita
rodado em sentido horário
agora se levanta seu pé direito e tenta
rodar no sentido anti horário
obrigado a tentar mesmo você querendo
fazer isso
o seu cérebro que fala assim não não é
assim que eu quero funcionar porque uma
coisa desse tipo acontece porque quando
você dá um produto desse pessoas o
cérebro dela falou o seguinte isso é uma
roupa
então eu vou usar essa roupa de uma
forma que essa roupa represente um
estilo pra mim você acha que ele está
preocupado em tapar o sol não está
preocupado com o estilo ninguém chega
numa loja para comprar um boné e falou
assim eu queria um boné que tivesse uma
aba grande o suficiente que tapasse o
sol do rio porque o sol do rio ele tem
um ângulo diferente
ele faz eu queria que o boneco que ele é
verde e tem o símbolo do flamengo ea
gente tenta então fazer pesquisas que
primeiro tentam prever corretamente
funciona a partir da previsão de começar
a mente funciona a gente tem como
desenvolver produtos que sejam
específicos precisamente até que você
tenha uma solução de um problema que
você nem sabe que você tem aquele
problema ainda e deixa eu dar um exemplo
prático de como a gente fazer isso
os nossos olhos por exemplo eles fazem
movimentos que a gente não percebe que
ele faz
então por exemplo fiz uma pesquisa uma
vez onde eu colocava um rapaz
do lado da namorada aí eu passava e eu
tinha essa máquina que controlava os
movimentos oculares a gente chama isso
de a entrega
então coloquei o rapaz do lado do
namorado e eu passava um vídeo e
falarmos em assistir o vídeo e nesse
vídeo passava uma menina super gostosa
com a roupinha curtinha e eu fiz isso
justamente pra ver se o senhor rapaz
olhava pra menina
passei o vídeo e depois perguntei pro
rapaz e outra menina que passou ele o
leilão do lado da namorada namoradas
olho no leilão
depois a gente foi lá o movimento ocular
da menina passando o olho do moço
rapidinho aí quando ela foi saindo frame
mas ele não ele não mentiu que
provavelmente ele estava tentando olhar
porque né a gente sabe dos perigos que a
gente corre e mas o olho fez esse
movimento porque esse movimento e não
naquele voluntário ele é muito rápido ea
gente não percebe que a gente está
fazendo
então a gente tem por exemplo no google
um óculos que mede exatamente isso
então uma das pesquisas que a gente pode
fazer o seguinte se eu quero saber
exatamente onde que pra onde que a
pessoa olha quando ela está usando um
celular
eu posso colocar um óculos e dessa
pessoa e simplesmente falar assim
uso o celular então pra só para dar um
exemplo muito específico é todo mundo
hoje em dia tem um smartphone
e a gente tem um telefone que eu acho
que devia mudar de nome porque ninguém
nos isso aqui pra fazer ligação mas mas
a gente usa para tirar fotos e toda vez
que a gente vai tirar foto agente
posiciona o celular de uma certa forma o
nosso dedo tem que naturalmente onde o
seu o o o botãozinho para tirar foto
está lá porque esse botãozinho tiver
muito pra dentro da tela vai tentar
fazer isso vai derrubar o celular vai
quebrar vai ficar triste ainda
provavelmente ainda tem mais 15
prestações para pagar sequer e na
primeira prestação muito tempo você vai
ficar sem celular
se o botãozinho está muito aqui embaixo
fica ruim de você colocar o seu dedo
porque ele pode por exemplo interferir
no menu do celular é uma coisa que a
gente faz por exemplo a gente coloca
pessoas para tirar foto com esse óculos
a gente olha exatamente para onde a
pessoa está olhando na tela a gente
consegue fazer uma coisa que chama
remetem onde a parte mais vermelha é
onde a pessoa tende a fixar o olhar e
neste caso aqui faz sentido porque a
foto o do objeto que a pessoa quer tirar
foto tá bem aqui no meio mas a gente
quer saber exatamente por onde a pessoa
olha quando a gente tem um menu aqui pra
onde que a pessoa olha quando a gente
tem objetos aqui ea gente faz esse
estudo de maneira
utilizando uma metodologia científica
muito rígida e tentando prever que a
gente dá várias funções a gente pede que
a pessoa fosse não quero você tira uma
foto e compartilhe com alguém
quero que você tira se for essa foto e e
apaga essa foto depois ea depender de
como da função que a pessoa está fazendo
com aquela foto naquela hora ela vai ter
padrões de olhares diferentes a gente
pega isso cria 11 na média geral ea
gente tem por exemplo exatamente onde
esses botões tem que ficar e para onde a
pessoa tem que olhar quanto tirar uma
foto e qual é a mensagem então que fica
disso o primeiro a ciência
ela não precisa estar contida dentro
dessa casa que a gente chama
universidade ela pode começar aqui mas
ela não precisa ficar contida que ainda
mais se você tiver recepções que deixem
triste se você não tiver restrições que
te deixem triste sem fique nessa casa
segundo a universidade
ela tem que começar a preparar o
profissional para poder sair dessa casa
se ele quiser porque o que acontece
muitas vezes é que o profissional não
sai dessa casa porque ele fica ansioso
ele fala assim porque eu casei com isso
eu casei com consciência nessa casa
se eu sair eu sou um perdedor e não é
bem assim
tem espaço lá fora não precisa de você
você e curtindo o problema é achar o que
você pode fazer fora da academia e o
segundo ea terceira mensagem que eu
queria deixar a seguinte esse casamento
com a ciência é um casamento fantástico
você nunca vai se arrepender desse
casamento e você tem que tentar o tempo
inteiro resolver problemas de forma pra
se você tem uma pergunta investigue
aquela pergunta e pensa em soluções
práticas para aquela pra aquela pergunta
específica que você tem e nunca nunca
nunca caso com alguém por obrigação e
para mostrar que essa tecnologia
funciona 100 anos do dc menina bonita
aqui favor para tirar um self para eu
falar de todo mundo no brasil 12 em já o
empregado
[Aplausos]